heads up guys my name is Hoshino
and welcome to an entirely new series in
which I'm going to look through all of
my past a lot of day games or the good
ones I should say and and say hi and see
how we can improve them will basically
just review them I'll talk about or like
how I made them essentially I'll talk
about the things that I wish I had time
to do I'll talk about the things that I
did wrong right as especially because a
lot of these things are very old and I
wasn't a particularly great programmer
back then in fact I'm on I'm still kind
of like back then like I was just
starting out so they weren't really
there are a lot of things there that I
did very very wrong
which i think is awesome because it
means that I can show you what I did
wrong and if you're kind of in the same
boat if you're learning programming and
if you're not sure what you're doing
then me being able to show you guys hey
this is what I did this is what I did
like wrong this is how I would do it now
is actually gonna be pretty helpful it's
also gonna let me kind of reflect on on
on on how my style has more or less
changed and how I approach problems
nowadays which is also kind of important
to look at so as you can see I've got a
face cam here I was tossing out whether
or not to include a face cam but you
know I mean I know you guys want to see
my face so I thought that it would be
better to just include it because
particularly because I've found that the
videos where I have a face cam and but
when I'm watching other people with a
face cam it kind of just makes it a bit
more personal it makes it a bit better
so I think I think it's a good idea so
let me know what you think about that
but I usually only have it on for live
streams but now I'm thinking of pretty
much including in in all my videos so
yeah we'll see how that goes but anyway
we're gonna start off with a game called
Genesis now one thing I want to do real
quick let me just see if I can let me
just see if I can find
my list of armed air games alright so I
got this list of games that I've made
full of them there as well as a few kind
of logs right so we're gonna start off
with the first one obviously Genesis
which was a lot um dare 24 this was a
while ago this was like August 2012
right this was basically the first game
that I ever made right I'm I did make a
game in about 2006 using game maker game
make a 6.0 I think it was version 6 when
I was still in like junior school pretty
much which is like elementary school
that was a long time ago and that wasn't
really programming or anything so this
was kind of the first game that I would
say I actually made from scratch at
least right because I made this in Java
with like no game engines nothing and
yeah I mean I kind of liked it there are
a few really big issues with it that
we're gonna talk about but in terms of a
game I actually quite liked this game so
I mean it's my first game I gotta like
it right so we're gonna kind of cover
that we might skip squared and then we
but we will definitely look at time
shudder and particularly beneath and I
think that'll be it
because evacuates made in JavaScript so
I didn't care about that shift was made
in C++ using Sparky and like growth was
made like that these games are kind of
alright like I mean growth I remember I
made this in about 8 hours so they were
like a lot of shortcuts I took in terms
of programming but these like these
games more or less I've got a lot I've
got a lot that I want to say and a lot
that I want to fix about them so will
definitely become will definitely be
covering them and we'll see how this
stuff goes but basically we're gonna
start off with Genesis and we're going
to here it is on github by the way it's
github duck home full slash the cherry
full / Genesis right when I start off
with that and we're essentially just
going to kind of see how it goes
I don't know how many episodes this will
be but this kind of Genesis part of this
series because we'll be looking through
like all that a lot and bag and it's but
we'll start off with Genesis this will
probably be like 10 episodes of
something in itself right because there
are a lot of things that I want to
mention as well as I want to obviously
open up the card for you guys to answer
to ask questions that you want me to
answer right so go ahead and take a look
at the code if you haven't already
cloner you can download it you can do
whatever you want with it right and if
there's anything bad that you kind of
don't understand or you're like why did
you do this
this is stupid keep in mind this is like
basically as I said my first game so
yeah there's a lot of stuff here that's
pretty bad sure no color dot Java anyway
we'll discover some cool stuff here I'm
sure but if you have any specific
questions then feel free to just drop
them in the comments below we're
probably like the scheduling for these
episodes is probably gonna be one awake
maybe two a week but definitely not more
than that right so there'll be a few
days between episodes I'm always going
to record them and then immediately post
them as well
so it's not like I'm bulk doing like ten
in a row and again like because my
schedule personally is very busy and
it's all over the place so whenever I
have time I want to sit down record an
episode and before doing that I'll look
at the comments and see if there's
anything I should mention so anyway
we're gonna start off with a clean kind
of check out of Genesis when a clone it
and then we're going to see kind of
where it leads us so this is kind of the
introductory episode as you can see
because I have been literally talking
about like introduction stuff for a
while now so we're just gonna take a
look at it briefly I'm gonna kind of go
through the card now I haven't looked at
these right that's that's the thing like
I haven't actually looked at these yet
like I didn't just have a browse through
the card and now I've got a list of
things I want to talk about I actually
don't know and there's gonna be kind of
like a live series as well alright so
I've got it open in eclipse here one
thing you can do by the way and I've
I've mentioned this before but all you
can all you need to do is just drop in
all this stuff like make a folder called
Genesis in your workspace directory for
eclipse if you're using eclipse I will
be making folder called Genesis put all
this code in it and then just like
basically right-click new Java project
and then type in the name of that folder
which if you call Genesis will just be
Genesis right and that will just
automatically set everything out for you
now keep in mind here that also I think
the sound is there WAV files so there's
a like pretty big I think it's about
there's about 70 megabytes of resources
but anyway once you close this and set
it up in eclipse let's continue right so
he
we have it I haven't liked again I
haven't looked at this code in like the
four years since I wrote it so let's
kind of go through this I guess I'm not
sure how this is going to be structured
again there's gonna be completely live
series I'm not gonna try and pretend
that it's gonna be produced well or that
it's gonna be like rehearsed or scripted
or anything like this it's gonna be
completely live so here we go when I
begin with the game class the game class
is where it begins
and we'll kind of probably go through a
bunch of these classes and all more or
less just reminisce about it and give
you guys a bit of a review of this stuff
and then I think starting like next
episode and onwards we're gonna start
looking at specific things and probably
rewriting specific things and and by
then off obviously I will put together
some kind of list of dot points I think
of things that are bad okay so what do
we have here I kind of look at the ideas
first so we have a the the thing was
evolution I used the dictionary to
define that so it's a gradual
development of something especially from
a simple to a more complex form sure so
time could control change evolution of
character levels may be something
evolves here at night when night comes
character involves and monster or
something during the night he can kill
freely but during the day is completely
harmless
so all great ideas that were pretty
ambitious and again I ended up going
with something really simple because I
ran out of time but kind of interesting
to look at kind of what my initial ideas
were for the for the game and stuff
which probably play the game first
shouldn't we that's probably a good idea
let me just run it sweet all right so um
I hope the audio isn't I might just mute
the audio because I don't know how loud
it is and I don't want it to cut off my
voice so no I'm sure it won't I'll just
lower it a lot how about that because it
musics quite nice because I wrote it
anyway let's look at the main menu so we
have the help sir hey what's up guys my
name is a trainer and welcome to a game
that's good
the game has a has quite a simple
concept use the arrow keys or WI steak
aid if that's how you roll to reveal
character this was I was 17 when I made
this game otherwise this is interesting
your aim is to evolve your colony you
must find women and
through them creating a baby or two it's
realistic every time you do this the
rate of growth that your population will
experience is increased
I like this shadow that I've dropped
behind the text by the way which means
more women but here's the catch you only
have five minutes to build a large
population this world has ever seen
also you can't breed with the same Woman
twice sorry I just love this game women
who have a green tag on them this was so
awesome women who have a green tag on
the mean they're available for breeding
while red means you've already nailed
them winky face
women can be women can be hard to find
however they always spawn in a similar
like this is great I absolutely love
this game this is the favorite game ever
made so try and find as many women as
you can to help grow the large
population ever of all you nation to the
maximum let's read the about Genesis is
a free game not good I'm glad I
mentioned it was free made by I like how
the how the environments getting darker
as well that was cold I like the idea of
this menu usually usually made menus I
make like most the main menus that I
make nowadays I think full of them the
air games are just like kind of simple
backdrop so it's like a background in
text but this actually has like
illegitimate like a level of the game
that's actually playing right now okay
which is pretty awesome I really like
that like look people are walking around
it's getting darker it's gonna start
getting it's gonna start like dawning
soon it's gonna get brighter as well
which is pretty cool anyway a free game
I might buy you on China cough that's my
real name in case you guys don't know
sir the Cherno for let him dare a 48
hour game developing competition this
game was made in just 20 hours however
due to me finishing year 12 my last year
of school so again I was 17 I was
finishing final year of high school and
having tons of work to do the theme for
the competition was evolution all assets
were made within 48 hours
alright so I'm one thing I wanted a nerd
is I remember that weekend because I had
a very like serious assignment that I
had to do and I actually pretty much
said you know what I'm just gonna like
butcher the assignment I don't
care I want to do a lot him Decker this
is what this is what this was my first
love in there as well and I just kind of
gotten up to the point where I was like
I feel like I can make a bit of a game
now so I remember I deliberately like
chose not to like I spend I spend like
very little time on that assignment and
I ended up getting like an e for that
assignment and I remember that and that
was pretty bad because like an E is like
probably like 40% or something right I
mean I remember like I'm trying to think
back to the marking system were using it
had a school and I think like a D was
like fifty to sixty percent at B was
like 60 to 70 C was 60 to 70 and yeah
like an a would have been like 40 to 50
and then a 20 to 40 or something I was
like an F are there looks like obviously
half classes and stuff and then I
remember zero to 20 was like ug which
was like ungrateful but anyway um I
remember I got an e for that was
terrible because that counted towards
like my high school like mark
essentially but I'm still managed to get
into the course that I wanted to get
into University so it didn't like
completely ruin my my life but like
actually I probably should have dumped
the school work instead of making this
game but actually looking back on it now
like I mean I I like to think that it
didn't like really it didn't ruin me too
much and I do have this wonderful game
to show for it so I'm actually pretty
happy that I went with that anyway this
was made for the 24th Naadam de comprar
my first entry for long there any
questions you can contact me by sending
an email through my email address or
checking out my youtube channel blah
blah so I've still got both both the
email address and the YouTube channel
good so for years I'm pretty stable
still have both of those both of these
things for more information and to watch
the recorded last year and the entire
game where you made that reminds me
there is actually a video I might link
in the description I might not of the
actual stream for this so the whole
stream I did stream it live and I
actually streamed it to YouTube I didn't
stream it to twitch now unfortunately
this was back when my internet was
particularly terrible and it's actually
still my parents place before I
convinced them to install good internet
and so because of that it liked the
video like constantly
like it's terrible like it just pauses
like it's good but sometimes it's like
it's terrible so it's basically
unwatchable there are there are paths in
it where it's smooth but I think most of
it is terrible it's just broken so I
don't know how helpful it would be but
if you google like genesis of youtube
Genesis
Cherno or something like a lot I'm dare
24sure know you'll find the livestreams
so if you really want to watch this
actually being made
again I've actually wanted to watch
those videos but I've been a V even
unable to watch them because they're so
terribly like broken so I don't know
good luck with that
thanks for playing cool I like that nice
little intro let's play it okay good so
we actually spawned into the riot it's
like the director's commentary so we
actually spawned it to the right level
there's a random chance a night this is
be going off memory by the way there's a
random chance of one of three levels two
of them don't work two of them don't
work properly we'll find out why and
we'll actually fix the bug in this
series but two of them don't work
correctly so this was a 33% chance of
getting into the good level and I I made
it so that's good good start so this is
like what I call the island one and this
one's we've got obviously five minutes
we can see that there's a woman here and
she's got she's ran into me so she just
and she nailed me instead of this it's
all backwards anyway uh she had a green
tag now he's got a red tag you'll notice
first of all and this is important
because people were asking me this a lot
and I don't just mean people in YouTube
I just mean people in real life as well
the children that you spawn are all male
okay so you are not you are not how
should I put this delicately
you are not breeding with your children
okay because you only spawn male
children okay so basically a more like
more females will just randomly appear
somewhere in the island but they are not
your children okay that's an important
that's an important note to make
okay now this is out of the way this is
going well you can see I've only a
really bread once not that's still the
same one you can see she's got a red tag
so the writer wishes population
increases depends on how much breeding
you've been doing you can see that the
you can there's kind of like lighting
going on like this is a bug right here
you can see that I'm kind of still lit
even though I'm outside of the light
right so I should be dark but I'm not
and maybe it'll randomly that'll just
pop in to working again but that's a bug
that we need to fix and also there was
the level bug oh that looks like a bug
as well you can say that the last pixel
in fact this is just happening
everywhere isn't it the last pixel seems
to be repeated you can kind of see how
that's said like the torch for example
the yellow that's something I just
noticed now ash I didn't think that was
a problem but that's something so it
looks like the last row of pixels is
being repeated for some reason though
I'd be happening to this side as well it
difficult to see no it's not happening
it's only the top ones interesting
wonder why probably something to do with
the rasterization I should mention this
was a complete like pixel engine that I
developed from scratch as well this was
very similar to the game programming
series in that regard this was actually
the basis for the game programming
series anyway I can't find anyone to
breed with just like in real life anyway
um I actually like I'm thinking of
restarting this cause a little dark
where is she Hey
okay cool so you can see only male
children and I've still I'm still live
cuz that's the lightning bug so the
right at which I can crisis is now hi I
want to get such a bad score as well
because I've been like looking at
torches instead of looking for women
anyway yeah so that lighting bug is very
annoying
also that weird lost like first row of
pixels as well it's actually really
annoying me all right anyway you guys
kind of get the point and then
eventually the time will run out and
it'll say game over and it'll say
something like tweet your score at me I
think I put that in most of my games and
yeah I mean this is a joke
yeah say for example she's still lit
even though she's out of the light so a
few lighting bugs here and there I quite
like the lighting though it's very cool
this also doesn't make sense I believe
this tile looks like it should be much
brighter or at least consistently bright
in fact it looks like it's just darker
so that's possibly something being
multiplied where it should be added I'm
not sure I don't remember how I did
lighting at all so I'm gonna have to
look at that and of course I wouldn't
have left comments I never do that oh
here we go
the air is still happening here like
with the you can see the last pixels
kind of being repeated or like the pixel
yeah essentially
okay so left left and left on top of
happening so the minimums so to speak
okay cool the code for this by the way
we're gonna look at the card and how
maybe maybe we should look at the card
next episode I think we'll do that I
think we'll do that because I'm running
out of time anyway and I've been talking
a lot but I hope you guys still kind of
enjoy that um I like talking and getting
my work done you know you know me but I
wanted to say that okay so game over
population 1200 exactly so that's skill
getting it exactly to 1200 is actually
pretty difficult to do so I'm I'm happy
with that anyway
yeah performance I think at one point
was about a hundred FPS so I wonder the
performance inconsistencies what they
like
if play again though okay so Alejandra
there's our first woman yeah that
repeating pixels something I've never
noticed before what one play in this
game not that I played often obviously
but
come here see one male child I made I
made sure to put that mechanic in don't
you worry um anyway oh this this round
is going better so I think next episode
will kind of walk through the code and
then from then on that'll be good as
well because you'll be you'll be able to
ask questions based on what I mentioned
whilst walking through the code in the
next episode so that'll be good but this
was kind of more of an overview of the
game I guess and just like kind of
comment commenting and reminiscing about
all the good times I had back in the day
so we out like that like 20 minutes yeah
20 minute episodes I wouldn't want to
aim for I think 10 to 20 minute episodes
they're pretty much my favorite length
of videos to do um anyway you guys can't
get the game so that's how it works
escape I believe yes will well um we'll
take you back to the main menu where you
can replay let's try and find another
level actually oh I may have disabled
the other levels I think I did let's
quickly enable the other levels main
menu maybe um where's the play thing see
if selected zero yeah that's what I'm
looking for if input don't use on
selected zero why is that not heal is
this I think yeah okay where is this
level top play equals true that's weird
as if I wouldn't like call a function
called play anyway you can see where
this is going like I have no idea how
this is written like this is gonna be me
kind of deciphering my own weird code
back in the day
anyway I'm assuming that the level it
chooses
it's probably is it like a play how does
it pick which level it wants to play
this is slightly embarrassing because I
have no idea how this works true
oh here we here it is of course so play
menu da biome is what sets the what was
it at - so - is the good one and then
obviously like this one for example a
forest one I think this was this was the
first one I made now there is a bug here
and the bug I'll mention what the bug is
instead of like instead of women
spawning within the level bounds
they actually spawn like in order to get
them to spawn in level bounds right I
got the width of the level which let's
just say is 40 tiles and then I
multiplied that with the amount of
pixels in each tile right basically by
doing that I'm ensuring that they can
spawn in at any given pixel because
spawning was done in pixels so what I
mean by that is like let's just say the
tiles are 32 by 32 and the levels 40
pixels wide right so they can spawn
anywhere between 0 and 1280 actually I
would have said select spawn regions so
that they don't spawn on trees or
whatever really writing calculators but
what I did is accidentally multiplied it
too much like I think I multiplied 2
again by tile size so it's like between
0 and like 40,000 or something and so
because of that obviously they mostly
spawn outside of the level and that's
kind of the bug so that was a bit
annoying and you can see because of that
these levels are basically unplayable
because whilst the levels of find
themselves you will not find women
essentially so they're pretty boring and
they just don't really flow well so
let's see if we can find the other one I
really like this level because it's like
snowy this is quite nice so we have
rocks and this unfortunately has the
same problem as the other one so only
the island level is safe I didn't
realize I disabled it maybe that was
like a post laden dare thing because I
did start doing some other stuff first
item dare I remember what such as adding
him adding like a mini-map as well again
then you have ice instead of water which
is kind of cool and the ice obviously
isn't animating
same way that the water was but yeah
this one's kind of cool you have the
snowy like treat treetops and it's
pretty cool the tree rendering is
something that's a little bit cool as
well because you can see that like you
kind of in front of this part let's see
if we can find a lone tree yeah tree
tree tree tree tree okay here we go so
like this part you're in front of but
this part you're behind mm-hmm pretty
cool huh so that was interesting you can
see that's I think the break is like
right there but it's yeah there it is
you can see kind of see where it but
yeah anyway that was another kind of
cool thing I think and then the lighting
of course this is quite nice when it
works correctly which is not usually the
case animating the tortoise would be
cool as well alrighty way I'm gonna stop
blabbering on about my game hope you
guys enjoy this video if you did please
hit a like button and next time we're
gonna take a look at every single line
of code in this we're gonna skim through
every single line of code in this in
this project and I'm gonna kind of try
and comment on some things and then from
then on we will pick certain specific
things to either rewrite or discuss or
talk about how you shouldn't write code
this way or how you should write code
this way and if you have any questions
of course the spawn on that spawn off
from the code review kind of episode
about like techniques or certain things
I did then obviously feel free to ask
away but also yeah yeah from then on
what we'll we'll definitely choose
specific things that we can take a look
at that I can either explain properly or
possibly even rewrite to make them
faster or better or just like written in
a better way so there's a lot of things
we're gonna do with this which is going
to be quite fun but if you enjoyed this
episode again please hit like button
helped see you guys next time goodbye
and this is a webcam episode I'm gonna
have to end this with warm